hello again citizens of the reject
Nation it's your boy jald flying solo
out here once more uh just left the
premiere of Disney Animation latest
feature wish commemorating 100 Years of
the studio which is pretty crazy to
think about leave a like for longevity
leave a like for 100 Years of Disney
before we hop into this just real quick
uh much like with the Creator I'm going
to give you my initial thoughts here
while they fresh of my mind and then we
are going to catapult forward a couple
days into the future where I'll be lucky
enough to speak with both the directors
as well as a couple of The Producers
behind wish get their thoughts and
perspectives on the process and see if
any of my takeaways are in any way
relevant to what they had in mind and
then you can take all of that and throw
it away and just go watch the movie and
and form your own opinion and uh and
that is what I wish for all of you
anyway what is wish about and how is the
movie wish tells the story of Asha a
sharp witted idealist who discovers that
the kingdom of Rosas in which she lives
and it's seemingly benevolent ruler king
magnifico are not as they seem in a
moment of desperation Asha makes a wish
so powerful that it is answered by a
cosmic force and together they must
confront the king and save Rosas I just
taught myself how to roll the RS so
you're just going to have to put up with
me for this one anyway that's the basic
gist and I got to say you know like I
went into this with pretty reasonable
expectations I mean obviously this isn't
aimed directly at me but I really enjoy
the tradition of Disney animated musical
movies and whatnot I love the art form
in general the trailers for this I found
to be pretty forgettable but given the
circumstances the Centennial and all
that stuff I was excited to see what
they would bring to the table and you
know this for me was one of those
experiences where like a quarter or a
third of the way into the movie you sort
of catch yourself and you're like oh man
I'm really getting into this and uh by
the end you know I was pretty much all
in this is definitely looking to embody
and homage the quintessential elements
that make and have made these Disney
animated movies what they are for you
know so many years now a century first
and foremost through its animation style
which brings a pretty interesting blend
of 2D and 3D inspired Traditions just so
many gorgeous watercolor backdrops
pencil sketch interludes things that
blend CG with more photorealistic
elements and it all came together into
something that you know felt a
cumulative of so much time and
Innovation and I found the tradition of
musicals this exists in pretty lovely as
well it always takes time and repeat
viewings for songs to find their place
or not among the pantheon of Classics
but I found the songs by Julia Michaels
and Benjamin rice to be largely catchy
and entertaining at very least in the
immediate moment the first time round
there were actually multiple times
throughout the movie where I'd catch
myself sort of transported and just
feeling like I was actually watching an
ensemble of dancers performing
choreography and singing on stage and
sort of reminding myself that like oh
yeah there's probably no cap or anything
this is probably just all in computer so
I mean the hats off I mean that's pretty
cinematic at least as far as I'm
concerned I can't really think of
another animated movie off the top of my
head that has given me that particular
kind of experience and that's absolutely
you know a testament to the combined
efficacy of all the elements working
together the songs the music the
animation the choreography Etc I thought
the voice cast did a quality job for the
most part especially Ariana deos and
Chris Pine as the two Central characters
in the movie Asha and K magnific with
Asha as your sort of spunky more modern
heroin dreaming of a better life while
also coming to grips with the harsh
reality that her beloved home isn't as
it appeared all these years there's a
lot in here about Truth versus the
status quo and standing up to tyranny
especially when it's hard entrusting
your hopes your dreams Your vitality to
systems greater than yourself For Better
or For Worse and in that sense when you
combine it with the main motif of wishes
and the Wishing Star it does coales into
something that feels timely and Timeless
with the major themes obviously being
pertinent to the current moment but you
know they're sort of always pertinent to
all of the Endeavor of human history
Chris Pine comes through with a villain
who's both Dastardly and Charming in
equal measure with some pretty delicious
musical numbers to boot complete with
the green magic flourishes love a good
villain number this movie's got him and
then you also have your requisite merch
character who in this case they've kind
of split off into two characters that
being the Wishing Star as well as
Valentino the talking goat star being a
more fanciful physical presence almost
like a Silent Age character in a way
while Valentino is here to supply us
with the non sequitors and onliners and
no shade to the character no shade to
Alan ttic I was excited to hear him
among the voice cast he does fine work
here uh and I'm sure plenty of people
are still going to go out and buy the
talking Valentino plushy or whatever it
is but just for my viewing experience
that particular thread of Comedy just
never really clicked in one way or
another his presence never really
detracted from the movie but it also
just didn't really add anything for me
either it was kind of there um but your
results will vary who knows maybe you'll
love them also a ton of nods and
references to various Disney Classics of
yester year some surprisingly subtle
others about as overt as you might
expect although to be fair nothing quite
approaching the shamelessness of
jepetto's branded wall of intellectual
property clocks from the recent
Pinocchio remake so there's that I think
my favorite was that asha's you know
little codery of friends all in their
own ways evoked the different Seven
Dwarves that was kind of a neat thing I
had to lean over to Wendy's during the
movie and be like am I crazy about this
or or is there a yeah okay shouts out to
the movie couple are some of the themes
a bit on the nose yeah could certain
character beats have benefited from a
little extra breathing room a little bit
more finesse absolutely but given who
this movie has to communicate most
clearly to and just the Vigor and
vitality with which it orchestrates all
of the rest of it it didn't ultimately
hamper or detract from or feel out of
touch with the tradition again that this
movie is seeking to embody homage and
celebrate kind of feels like a review
show of all those different elements
just with new songs and characters to
tie it all together and through that
perspective I came out pretty dazzled
feeling the magic appreciating the care
and craftsmanship is it Disney's
greatest film in a hundred years I don't
know man I mean you know probably not
but who knows regardless of where it
lands I got a lot out of it and if this
is something you know is for you I think
you're going to as well but anyhow those
are my thoughts I've yammered on long
enough I'm going to put the old old
iPhone away and we're going to go talk
to some of the real creatives who
brought this all to Life John 48 hours
later hello again citizens of the reject
Nation we are here in one of Walt
Disney's authentic and lovely offices
and we're going to be talking to Chris
and fawn the co-directors of wish as
well as Peter and Juan the producers of
wish uh let's jump into it and I'm going
to be super professional and refer to my
questions keep things on track
we know what it's like it's the first in
person I've done in a minute first off
uh Chris fun thank you guys so much for
taking the time out to chat with us
today I you know I'm obviously the
Target demographic for this movie um but
I honestly like whilst watching it and
expecting to at least have fun I got
real swept up in it so I first off just
congratulations because especially for
100 years it's got to be quite a feat to
pull it together and and with that you
know I'm I'm quite curious like was the
Milestone Centennial was that something
were thinking about a lot while making
this was that something that informed
your approach or were you mostly just
trying to focus on the work and kind of
leave that behind well it it informed I
mean a little bit of both I mean we were
always thinking about it it it did
inform the approach because knowing that
it was the 100th anniversary we felt you
know we really wanted to pay respect to
our Legacy right but also embrace the
technology that we have today so it was
the that came about in several things
and one of them was the look how do we
come up with a look that does that so it
was going back to Snow White going back
to penocchio and those gorgeous
watercolor I was going to say
illustration BL of Animation Styles and
the charcoals and and the photo real
certain elements like glass and things
like that yeah so going back to those
things and um and then but but being
able to use the the CG and the camera
work that we can do today but not going
overboard with because there was an
Elegance to the to the the older films
you know and a restraint when it came
came to the camera you didn't want to
always zip around yeah there are times
we use that were times we move but there
was also we were very conscious of that
having that we kept using the word
Elegance of the camera work so um think
that was that was uh definitely that was
always going through our heads as you
say you know throughout the whole movie
beautiful another thing that kind of
struck me again you know alongside the
animation and the tradition of all that
uh multiple times and I don't know if
this was intentional I found myself kind
of feeling as if I was watching an
actual stag musical Ensemble and then
reminding myself oh no this is all
probably in computer not motion or
performance captured or anything was
that an intentional thing you kind of
wanted to transport us to or is that
just a happy byproduct well because of
the aspect ratio we chose for this film
right the cinemascope the widest screen
possible it it provided us an
opportunity and a challenge to frame
this movie differently than what we have
done before the last time that was used
was Beauty um Sleeping Beauty and that
film is beautiful it's like a milestone
in in um how you compose a shot so we're
like okay we want to to give it our our
best and and do that and um that lead us
to certain shots we we would frame we
have philosophy of like if someone's in
control they're right in the center and
if there's imaginative feeling going on
the camera will start to spin so we have
all these guiding principles that we
share with our artists everywhere and
everyone's holding on to that from start
to finish I am so proud that we pulled
this off lovely I the first I mean you
know sticking within the the traditions
and all that you know you guys have
between the two of you certainly done a
lot with Disney and all that and now
you're co-directing together you've you
know directed a handful of these and
this as I understand is your sort of
first major directorial um you know what
did you kind of glean from Chris's
experience and Chris was there any
moment where it was like the student
becomes the teacher or you know this
sort of fresh uh perspective is is sort
of broadening your pallet too we get to
connect on um you know the the the
topics of when you have a passionate
wish in your heart what do you do about
it how do you go about it right and and
we um look at our own lives and journey
and are able to share with each other
our story which I find very special
getting to know Chris more and getting
to work with Chris and see how he
navigates certain things you know there
will be stuff that comes up that I feel
like I'm very passionate about this
topic but sometimes I'm well I don't
want to slow people down this is a
production you know the machine is going
forward and Chris had taught me that if
there's something in you that you like
hold near to your heart just just you
know stick with it like put your foot
down and and express that not just keep
it to yourself express that to everyone
because the solutions can come from
surprising places sure mhm and you'd
rather you know throw the idea out there
or at least pursue it then regret not
doing that at all yeah yeah so for me it
was a because we we come from different
sort of creative backgrounds hers is
more in the story end of it mine's more
in the animation end of it um you know
there's so many times that I would
really listen to Fawn and her her um
just how she would get into the
characters get into the scene and their
motivations and really think about it
because when you're storyboarding you
are really in the head of the character
and you're every move why there's a
camera move why there's this um and so
she would bring that to the directing
end of it and always think about those
character and always ask those questions
which was great and sometimes uh you
know we both would she would ask the
questions to the room and the room might
go I don't
know that's a great question let's
figure that out let's come up with an
answer but it always made the the story
stronger and the character stronger for
that so I was learning from that that
aspect lovely I guess uh they're giving
me the wrapup but last but not least I
mean this is a movie certainly filled
with lots of loving nods and references
to the swath of you know the Disney
Pantheon were there any of those that
were like your particular baby that you
wanted to make sure got a
nod my favorite and I don't know if you
got to see the whole film all the way
through the credits I believe past the
credits there's a big knot at the very
end okay I don't know if you remember
but it's past as the credits roll and
are done there's another there's a tag
at the end okay and that is my favorite
and I'm not going to say what it is stay
tuned
stay not just for Marvel did you did you
have one it's uh it's not as Grand as
that but I love beauty the Beast and uh
throughout this production I kept
wanting to put a cup that has a chip
mark on it yeah and I just kind of like
maybe this scene maybe that scene and
those scenes keep getting like we we cut
them and I'm like goodbye goodbye chip
but at the end we found a place for it
and and I I asked production like can we
and they were like yes we will make that
happen put it right in on the screen I
don't know if you saw it or not it's but
I when when I see it now I'm like yes
thank you that's my that's my well
beautiful guys thank you so much for for
chatting with me I really really had fun
with the movie and uh I wish you all the
best thank you thank you thank
you who what are you doing Valentino
don't eat
that
it didn't work when does the magic
happen I'm talking I'm talking who knew
my voice would be this
low 1 hour later first of all uh I know
I'm the Target demographic for this
movie and uh I was really dazzled by it
like honestly I wouldn't expecting to
enjoy myself and I got completely swept
up like I was a kid so first of all just
congrats on on a great great uh final
product and I'm very curious you know
this is uh you know you've both done a
lot of notable work with Disney over the
years this is the Centennial celebrating
a 100 years what does that Milestone
mean to you and did it Foster any
particular sort of guiding principle
when assembling the teams and keeping
everything on track for the vision of of
wish it's not lost on us we're here at a
very particular moment in time and with
that you know comes a lot of
responsibility and and uh but the joy is
that everybody wanted to work on this
project everybody wanted to be a part of
celebrating the 100th anniversary what
was important to us the guiding
principle was we wanted to make sure
that we were telling an original story
with original characters and original
songs that was most important and that
the movie should evoke all of the
emotions of things that we like about
the past Disney movies and words like
you know Hope and Dreams and wishes and
wishing on Stars was very prevalent we
want to make sure that that that was
embodied in the film yeah no I think you
you did a terrific job at that and um
you know moving on you know this is
obviously celebrating the swath of
Animation in terms of you know the
various media and you know there's
sketch and there's computer and there's
stuff that looks like watercolor and
things like that how much of that was
part of your vision you know for this
did you have a very distinct idea of
what you wanted the film to look like
visually uh well no yeah well what I
would say is from very early on our
directors and production designers uh
knowing that this was the movie that uh
celebrated the anniversary and it being
a fairy tale they wanted to allude to
that so they looked to our first movies
like Snow White and Pinocchio which are
also fairy tales to bring in a little
bit of that DNA but we also wanted it to
feel different and fresh so our artists
really worked with our technology team
to push it forward and this I mean this
is to me you know it's telling both a
very classic fanciful tale you've got
this very innocent and very you know
lovely idea of the wishes and the
Wishing Star but you're also you know
doing a very relevant cautionary tale
about you know complacency and tyranny
and and trusting your livelihood to
systems Beyond yourself what was your
approach to kind of balancing those
tones and making something that has all
those Timeless qualities but feels very
pertinent I mean we always say that we
want our films be both timely and
Timeless and these movies hopefully you
know are watched you know Generations so
it has to stand on its own uh but the
idea of wishes and you know uh you
should never you know give up on your
wish you should certainly never let
anybody control your dreams and your
aspirations so that was an important
part of the message absolutely uh and
another thing this is just a personal
thing that that kind of struck me while
watching the movie but I I would catch
myself multiple times while in one
breath admiring the animation flourishes
also feeling like I was watching a live
staged musical is that something that
you were striving for or is that just
kind of a happy byproduct of the you
know you know I I didn't really notice
until we were at the premiere watching
with an audience it did have that
feeling and I think it was because you
know the audience was clapping after
after every song and laughing right
along with the so there was a palpable
connection between the audience and the
screen that you know it's it's a
wonderful reminder of why we want to see
these films in a theater and I think the
masterfulness of the writing both from
our screenwriters Jen and Alison and our
songwriter Julia is is is just
phenomenal because they found a way that
the songs really push the movie Forward
right so the songs are telling the story
as well and that's what a great stage
musical does MHM absolutely yeah and I
mean obviously this is celebrating and
nodding directly to you know various you
know the classic Disney stories and
whatnot were there any little moments or
Easter eggs that you know you Champion
for in particular either one of you or
you're like I got to have my you know
nod in
here I I think the only thing that that
we pushed for uh is to make sure it felt
organic to the storytelling we didn't
want it to just be about that um uh and
so I'm really happy with with the way
it's turned out yeah absolutely yeah and
I guess my final question is you know so
many of these stories Focus especially
lately focused in on a particular
culture and what I thought was
interesting is Rosas is sort of a Haven
for many cultures and that felt like
kind of a unique and and and new way of
incorporating and and representing
people on screen how did you guys
approach that quality of the movie well
it was very organic to the story because
in the story we were creating a kingdom
where people from all over came because
who who doesn't want to get their wish
granted so you would travel there no
matter where you're coming from and we
also we wanted it to be a fairy tale so
it's a period piece in the medieval
times and we did our research uh we
wanted to feel like that Disney fairy
tale so it had that European element but
also to have that element of the story
of people from all over the place we
found that area in the Mediterranean
actually did have people from different
areas because it's between continents
it's between the sou of Europe and then
North Africa so we have an
anthropologist help us with the World
building and all of that so as all of
our movies there like this one is very
much a fantasy place it's a believable
world uh but uh but it is it is grounded
in reality because you need to start
somewhere absolutely it feels that way I
think you guys did a nice job of
collectively all of you you know
bringing that to life and uh and yeah I
really appreciate you taking the time
out to talk to me really enjoyed the
movie and wish you luck on whatever's to
come thank you thank you cheers
[Music]